that's fair who's your goat like who's
the greatest of all time to you in terms
of hip-hop [__] Michael
yeah yeah you know I like living in
Florida like you know how like people be
like oh
like when they come to park and [__]
they like Park got a song for every
situation type [__] that's why they all
right he got a song for every situation
you know it's funny because like I
didn't unders because I'm a West Coast
guy but I lived in Tampa for like three
years yeah I lived there
when he got out the last time he got out
and
I didn't I I always like enjoyed boozy
music and [__] and him and Webby [__]
but I didn't really understand like
the gravity of what he means to the
South until I lived there
and uh when he put his album out I think
he called it like
boopac or some [__] or um
I was like I get it because he's a lot
of people's Tupac yeah he's a lot of
people's Tupac for real like listen to
that throwback boost yeah and he's he's
he looked like he had did you meet him
uh have you met him yet yeah I don't
know it was he didn't disappoint did he
uh no he it was crazy because he knew me
he feels right like just you know I'm
saying me being on him growing up you
feel me like how I was on him [__] and
now you see me you know me his kids
don't know what I'm saying listen to my
music famous it's got a lot of them yeah
if you get all the Boosie's kids
together that's a stream Farm if you
wanted it to be
um
I always tell I tell everybody boozy
like when you meet him because I've met
a lot of my favorite rappers growing up
and like I I've been disappointed by a
few of them like where they were either
just not who I thought they were and
they were [__] not him he's like as
advertised yeah not for sure he was
cutting up at the BT Awards too man
yeah did you see him fall when he was
trying to rip the plastic off of himself
when Lotto was performing nice see that
it's so funny
it was happening
oh [__]
um for you like do you have I mean you
could educate me do you have like an
imprint a label yourself that you're
yeah like that wild child when you hear
Wild Child I see the chain wild child
that's that's your label that's the
brand for sure for sure okay a couple
years from now you're gonna see that
[__] everywhere not even a couple years
I give it a year
do you like have you have you um
you know try to get some advice from
Gotti like hey once I'm ready to start
signing artists what should I do for
sure
yeah the sofa so have you gone to a
soccer game with him yet because he owns
a soccer team no not yet where's the
team at is it in DC yeah DC yeah I feel
like that's I definitely got a question
we were just talking about soccer too I
got a kiss have you been to the casino
with him no I feel like you shouldn't go
because I saw a video of him and I think
he like lost like a
Preposterous amount of money so you
think I think he ain't one thing about
it I think Jay-Z might have been
standing there and getting sweating you
think if I beat up I'd be that good be
that good that look so this is the thing
if you go gambling with somebody
who's willing to like put six figures on
like a single spin or hand yeah
then you start thinking in your head
it's a good idea
and then you might try to like not see
me personally I ain't gambling or
Gambler well what do they got like a
hard rock somewhere over there in
Jacksonville I think there's one in
every major floor nah in Jacksonville I
don't got nothing but like little Best
Bets the closest Hard Rock would
probably be like um Tampa
well I've had some nights at that
[__] yeah oh
have you ever have you been to Vegas
yeah I haven't been to Vegas I love
Vegas did you notice the random
prostitutes late at night sitting at
slot machines by themselves while they
had baby fat purses hanging from their
arms no I never noticed that yeah it's a
thing yeah yeah you go to a big I just
live in Vegas
I've lived everywhere you go to Vegas if
it's three in the morning and you see a
chick that's like a six or better
she's at that slot machine by herself
and she's done up like you know like oh
you look like you might have just left
the club yeah or a job interview she's a
prostitute
for sure
or any casino you go to you go to the
high limits room and you go to the high
limit bar and there's just a plethora
that's where the wonderful ones are the
casino floor is where you know the lot
lizards are as we like to uh limited
liquor for the bottles yeah yep yep yep
but if you ever go to the Tampa Bay Hard
Rock they're all disgusting
it's bad
I've never participated in such
activities but I am very very uh you
know aware of my surroundings at all
times I like to know what's going on
gotta watch this around